Jamie starts off this hour in Denver hey
Jamie how are you hi Dave I'm great how
are you better than I deserve what's up
my husband father wants to give us a
gift a very large amount of money my
husband doesn't want to take it and I'm
not sure how to speak to my husband
about this okay why does he not want to
take it well in the past his father he
felt that his father has kind of
critiqued him about his life and he
feels that the gift will come with
strings in that his father's going to be
able to have being able to have a
dialogue with him about his career which
i think is fine you know but my husband
thinks that that he'll be attacked in
that so why is your husband an insecure
about his career he's kind of wavered
back and forth and he's in a really good
spot right now he's a coach and he's
he's making $70,000 a year like I think
he's doing great has father's in the
investment business and so he you know
he's worth millions and millions of
dollars and so he I think he feels
intimidated about speaking with his
father so then like his father is kind
of laid out that he wants to give this
large monetary gift if kind of like if
if I can talk to you if you'll have a
relationship with me sort of like you do
with your will I think they were you're
saying if anyone women so you just don't
have a really you guys don't have a
relationship with him now we do we live
two blocks away from him what's that
well now with the River Hood I'm sorry
the relationship you have a relationship
so it's not if I can have a relationship
with you it's if the substance of the
relationship changes that's what it is
if he wants it to be deeper he wants to
be able to speak with his son about more
than the weather and so that boundary
has been put up because in the past the
old man's been controlling well I don't
know if it's been controlling I haven't
seen it we've been married for two years
so I haven't seen the control side as
much as I've just seen his dad say like
hey let's be direct and honest and open
what are you doing with your life I just
want to know and it's because his dad
put him through school through
University and that's why you know like
his dad wanted to know like hey how's
your career path going on paying for
your school I want to know what's going
on and my husband hasn't been real
direct with him he's just been kind of
intimidated I think and scared to talk
to his dad and now his that is your
husband 44 okay um Wow I don't know are
you guys in a good church yes and we're
going to a Christian meridah meridah
counselor as well yeah I think I would
talk to through with your marriage
counselor with your pastor um I I can't
tell I mean I what's going on here on
the one hand it sounds like your
husband's a wuss and on the other hand
sounds like his father-in-law's an ogre
his father than ogres I can't tell it
may be some combination of those two
things um so if you're 44 years old you
still cow in the presence of your father
something seriously broken in this
relationship process you know and I
don't know what it is but I mean that's
pretty dadgum big deal it's not like
it's 22 year old kid you know so I mean
obviously there there's a lot going on
here that's more that money's not going
to solve so I think I would pass on the
money until we solve the relationship
issue well the issue is the lawyers are
signing the paperwork because it was a
trust set up for his grandmother and she
passed away
no one also here they can do whatever
they want to do with it I'll pass and
it's it's over a million dollars okay oh
okay
am i giving up my manhood for a million
dollars hmm so uh I mean you know it
doesn't have to be a permanent pass but
until but I'm not going to say okay a
million dollars buys you the right to
get all up in my business and the
starting relationship reopened that's
going to make you all miserable it's not
worth it you're going to be dying
that but now I might say okay let's tap
the brakes here go ahead and drop it
into a trust or drop it into something
else dad and we'll work on our
relationship and as our relationship
gets to the point you feel good about it
then you want to move some of it that's
fine but we're not going to do money and
then you come over here and start
walking through my house with muddy
boots that's not happening hmm that's
what he's afraid of and apparently he's
got a reason to be afraid of that
I don't know what it is talking to you
and I'm not a family counselor I'm just
a guy but um you know guys and their
dads always have an issue of some kind
John John elder drove about that
beautifully in the book wild at heart
and called it the father wound and and
you know we guys love our dads but
there's always that thing and that's my
son I mean he has to overcome being my
son god help you through my kid you know
so um you know and yet he and I eat
breakfast every Thursday morning we
spend time together I'm seeing tomorrow
I love the guy he's a great young man
all of that but he's got overcome being
my son you know and that's just part of
life but I this sounds like it's a
little bit more than that and I can't
tell what it is
so I I would no I would not accept a
million dollars in this circumstance
because there's something going on here
that that's just weird that's just weird
so you know we need to rebuild our
relationship and then if you choose
based on that to give us money that's
fine but you give me money and with that
comes this now now I think it's
backwards and I can't tell what's going
on here I just can't I can't you know
but I think you guys need some counsel
on it and how to get your husband's get
your husband up to the point that he can
deal with his dad on a reasonable level
which right now he doesn't feel like he
can tell us that no and if his dad
actually entered the conversation and
you know you have to reach that point no
no so I get some counsel take your time
with this get the relationship heal
first then accept the money that would
be my opinion but just take the money
and deal with the crap that he's going
to open up a can of worms
thanks for calling it hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you are not a
victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim